when the universe was born
it expanded very rapidly
in a very short period of time known as
Cosmic inflation as the universe
expanded
these Quantum fluctuations were
stretched and the stretching
needed the universe with tiny peoples
these ripples yet
are the origin of galaxies Galaxy
clusters planets the Earth and people
the mystery here is is a really possible
that a submicroscopic entity like a
Quantum fluctuation
could eventually grow into the Milky Way
galaxies if you had told me that a few
years ago I would have thought but you
ran out of your mind
and yet today the standard model of the
formation of cosmic structure is exactly
what I just described